I remember condensate another you know
you've got it's not comparable to any
other nation in the world
terrible human rights violations are
beyond anyone's imagination those things
are happening in North Korea right now
[Music]
this is the North Korea that Kim jong-un
would like you to know a nation of high
rises in the capital city of Pyongyang
the impressive Arirang festivals of mass
culture and recreation and a pervasive
national pride that looks a lot like
state religion a short bus ride away
from the well-rehearsed happiness there
is extreme poverty famine and a network
of prison camps that's reminiscent of
the worst atrocities of Nazi Germany
Shin dong-hyuk not only escaped a prison
camp but he's on a mission to tell you
everything he knows through his
translator mr. Shin spoke with reason
last week in Washington DC tonight well
I was born in a political prison camp in
North Korea I was expected to just do
manual labor and to work and I had no
concept I had no rights I had no concept
of what the human rights were I was
destined to live and die in this prison
camp
well all the inmates know that that
prison camp is surrounded by electrified
fence and that there are prison guards
that stand guard however there was no
way for the prisoners to know what was
beyond the electrified fence whether it
was another a world of prison camps and
there was no way for us to know even
going further than that my own mother
and father I never talked to me about
the outside world
- and Abigail I know that my mother and
father met and were quote unquote buried
in the camp my guess is that datum
selves were sent at a very very early
age - the prison camp and that's how
they ended up being the camp and how
they met one another hegwood oh my
witness there my mother's a public
execution in the camp at age of 14 and
the result of that was that I myself was
very severely mistreated and went
through a terrible suffering regarding
that I never questioned or doubted what
my life was all about in the prison camp
of course now when I look back I
the very terrible and horrible existence
obviously there are other defectors who
have been incarcerated in the political
prison camp system in North Korea and
were able to either escape successfully
or were released and then escaped North
Korea we all know the the new young
leader Kim jong-un is a dictator just
like his grandfather and his father who
was given the dictatorship to me
personally I have no expectation that he
will be any different or will rule
differently from his father or
grandfather as I traveled throughout the
world I've met I meet a lot of about
different politicians many leaders and
NGO and other organizations but
unfortunately I really haven't been able
to find a clear-cut answer or a specific
answer from these people or from these
meetings and one of the things that I
always do when I visit these cities
whether it's LA or Washington DC or
cities in Europe is I try to find and
visit any Holocaust museums that are in
the world I try to visit them as much as
possible so yesterday during my stay
here I had the chance to visit again the
US Holocaust Museum here in Washington
DC and in one of the displays there was
a huge banner or picture and there was
one question that was on the wall why
didn't people bomb the railways that led
to the prison Nazi prison camp that
question obviously pertains to what
happened in the past 60 years ago during
World War two but my opinion is that
that question still applies to what is
going on right now as we speak
go to minute and I wonder what it is
either and nothing and I believe the
true answer or solution to that question
lies with the international community
the world community at large
you